an acting challenge so difficult it led
to stomach pains and a call to Mom
here's the uncomfortable movie scene
that Jennifer Lawrence struggled to film
Jennifer Lawrence has made a name for
herself as a grounded affable actress
who seems to tackle every new
challenging role with ease while fans
might take it for granted that as an
actress it's her job to handle each take
like a professional some scenes are more
difficult for Lawrence than others and
we're not talking about action scenes in
films like the X-Men franchise or The
Hunger Games for Lawrence one of the
hardest scenes she ever had to film
involved the intimate love scene with
her married co-star Chris Pratt in
2016's passengers in the film Pratt's
characters accidentally woken up early
from a state of suspended animation
while on a 120-year journey to a new
planet Pratt's gym decides to wake up
Lawrence's Aurora and the two fall in
love before having to contend with the
ship malfunctioning threatening the
lives of the other still sleeping
passengers however there's a certain
steamy scene that Jayla felt
particularly weird about before during
and after it's filming Lawrence opened
up about the scene during an actress
Roundtable for The Hollywood Reporter in
2015 talking about what was actually her
first real love scene she said she was
anxious about kissing a married man her
co-star Chris Pratt was married to
actress Anna Faris at the time I had my
first real sex scene a couple weeks ago
and it was really bizarre it was really
weird and everything was done right
nobody did anything wrong it's just a
bizarre experience as for how she dealt
with her anxiety over the scene I got
really really drunk but then that led to
more anxiety when I got home because I
was like what have I done I don't know
in a separate interview with Seth Meyers
the oscar-winning actress discussed how
she was paranoid about coming across in
a negative light
because like with sex scenes you don't
know what to do you're like is it too is
it enough is it but your worst nightmare
is is it too much
she continued by pointing out how it
felt uncomfortable to discuss the
specifics of the scene prior to filming
it's so much more uncomfortable for
Lawrence it seems like the best course
of action was to enjoy some wine to help
digest the situation while speaking at a
promotional event per Vanity Fair her
co-star Chris Pratt mentioned that above
all he wanted to make sure his co-star
felt comfortable she wanted to have some
wine so he did and that was nice but
even after they were done shooting the
scene Jennifer Lawrence said she was
self-conscious about how it went guilt
is the worst feeling in your stomach and
I knew it was my job but I couldn't tell
my stomach that Lawrence was so bothered
by the situation that she reached out to
her mom for reassurance so I called my
mom and I was like will you just tell me
it's okay it was just very vulnerable
and you don't know what's too much you
want to do it real you want everything
to be real but then that was the most
vulnerable I've ever been a her efforts
were worth it in the end as passengers
grossed more than 300 million dollars
worldwide making it one of the most
profitable original films from 2016. but
critics weren't as kind to the film the
Sci-Fi drama holds a 30 critics rating
on Rotten Tomatoes with the consensus
still one consistent bright spot among
the negative reviews was Pratt and
Lawrence's chemistry on screen sounds
like the discomfort was well worth the
final result
foreign